i do want to ask you a little bit about
editing
how long for example was your first cut
compared to the finished film
uh not that much different uh so i've
had the same editors since my first
movie they're some of my best friends i
have dinner with them every sunday night
back when we used to be able to have
dinner together but we've done that for
about a decade they're
just wrapped up cutting the stand uh so
you know i cut the basically 75
of this movie with them and then they
were cutting the stand already
when i finished it so i brought in
another editor to do the final stuff
with me so i mean
i don't know you just sit in there and
tinker but i'd say we were 75
done and then did the last percentage uh
just in the past year
got so uh how long is the movie can you
share that
oh yeah i think it's 98 minutes or
something like that it was never more
than i think 104 even at its longest you
know i think of my
initial i remember my initial cut before
we cut anything out was probably 20
minutes longer than that but uh
you'll see all that on the uh special
features we put together all the deleted
scenes for everybody
it was more just like stuff that was
either too funny or like uh
tonally just didn't quite go together
but it's cute character moments that i
think fans will like